Speaker 1: So the Florida Department of Education
recently decided to ban AP African-American
history. Now AP is relevant here. That means
advanced placement. These are not only elective
courses, but they are above and beyond that
courses that, depending on whether you take the
AP test, can actually go towards college credit
and optional elective. And a very small percentage
of students take these courses. And the reason
that Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is now giving
for the reason that this class has been banned
is completely and totally absurd. The department
says that the class was teaching students
activism, intersectionality, encouraging the war,
encouraging, ending the war on black, trans queer
and gender nonconforming and intersex people, that
it's queer theory and that it is indoctrination.
Now, again, this is not a mandatory class that's
being pushed on anybody. It's an elective class
that students can choose to take. If this is
subject matter they are interested in and they are
issues that should be determined from within the
community, not by Ron DeSantis in terms of what is
taught. DeSantis was asked about it during a press
conference, and here is what he had to say.
Speaker 2: Don't count the African-American
studies courses rejected by the
state and a lot of criticism of
that move. People saying, you know, this is
exactly what we are fearing with the individual
freedom bill. I don't know if you or the
commissioner could maybe expand a little bit more.
Speaker 3: Sure. I mean, I think so. You know, as
you know, in the state of Florida, our education
standards not only don't prevent, but they require
teaching black history, all the important things
as part of our core curriculum. This was a
separate course on top of that for advanced
placement credit. And the issue is we have Guy.
Speaker 1: So he admits that. That's interesting.
We're going to go back to the kinds.
Speaker 3: Of standards in Florida. We
want education, not indoctrination. If
you fall on the side of indoctrination,
we're going to decline. If it's education, then we
will do this core. So when I heard it, we didn't
meet the standards. I figured, yeah, they maybe
do a survey. It's way more than that. This course
on black history, what are one of what's one of
the lessons about queer theory? Now, who would
say that an important part of black history is
queer theory? That is somebody pushing an agenda
on kids. And so when you look to see they have
stuff about intersectionality. Abolishing prisons,
that's a political agenda. And so we're on that's
the wrong side of the line for Florida standards.
We believe in teaching kids facts and how to
think, but we don't believe they should have
an agenda imposed on them. When you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer theory, you are
clearly trying to use that for political purposes.
Speaker 1: So there's a couple of different things
that are important to talk about here. First
of all, I don't know me David Pakman. I don't
know whether queer. First of all, I don't know
whether queer theory is part of that course,
but let's imagine that it is. I don't
know whether it's correct. To have
a part of a course about black history include
queer theory. I don't know whether that's
appropriate or not. I don't think Ron DeSantis
knows either. He's not an expert on black history,
and neither am I. So the idea that if that is the
case, that that is part of the subject matter,
then the course is bad or wrong doesn't make a
lot of sense to me. That's first and foremost. But
again, this is an elective associated Associated
Press AP Advanced placement course. Okay. These
are, in a sense, college equivalency courses. When
I took AP Economics, for example, in high school,
I got college credit for that course. In college,
it would be completely normal to have more niche
classes of this style, and it would make sense
that the AP Black History course would differ from
whatever is taught to every high school student.
But what DeSantis and other people in Florida are
doing, it's sort of slick in a sense. They want
to act as though seven year olds are being taught
queer theory, for example, or that prisons should
be abolished. Even if it's true that those things
are in that course, this is not being taught to
first and second graders. This is an elective
college equivalency advanced placement class. But
they don't want to let the students make their own
decisions. Remember, nobody's going to be forced
into this course. Students, in consultation with
guidance counselors, their parents, whoever can
decide based on their interests whether this is
a course that they want to take. He's removing
the choice and proactively saying we're going
to get government involved to ban a class.
This is part of the decidedly anti LGBT bent,
by the way, that Ron DeSantis has been on. And
it's been extra clear lately. Just a few days ago,
DeSantis requested information from from
universities statewide of every student who has
I forget the exact wording, but basically
it's like a list of trans students, which,
as we've said in other states, Texas tried this.
It doesn't appear that that's actually legal. So
DeSantis is making his intentions very clear,
even though he claims to be small government.
Government shouldn't do something unless
absolutely necessary. It is not necessary to
get involved in banning this optional advanced
placement class. And that's what he's doing.
And instead of promoting education and promoting
understanding and promoting choice, hey, there's
things available to you. You can choose what it
is that you want to study, particularly if you're
looking at AP classes. It's instead censorship and
it is ignorance and it's all of those things. So
the class should be reinstated. Nobody should be
forced to take it. It is an optional AP class.
Might have been 12 students who were going to take
this thing, but they don't care. It's pathetic.
And it's very clear that this is again, people
like DeSantis loves to love to say the left is
virtue signaling coming out against this class
and trying to ban it and pretending like it's
being forced on children is exactly the type
of virtue signaling they claim to be against.